pêcher à l'état sauvage les crevettes
d'argentine sont très populaires depuis
quelques temps elles sont de bon calibre
et leur goût rappelle celui du homard
mais vous nous avez demandé comment il
est possible qu'un emballage de
crevettes d'argentine indique produits
de chine bairon vietnam ou thaïlande
surprenant en effet mais il faut savoir
que ces crevettes pêchées dans
l'atlantique sud au large de l'argentine
sont transportés par bateau aux usines
de transformation qui elles sont situées
principalement en asie pour y être
emballés avant d'être exportés vers le
canada
la mention produit de chine ou
d'ailleurs est non seulement possible
mais obligatoire